[Music]
all right guys i have a story here
and i have opinions here too i'm glad
that's actually what i want i got way
more opinions than you got story what do
you call it when you just
make [ __ ] up lies okay we got lies too
i think that's what we're really good at
storytelling just lying news
assuming making up [ __ ] just fibbing
news i want to hear a story thank you
so this story here is about this young
slovenian woman
who was recently she was recently
sentenced to two years in prison she
sounds like my kind of girl
for cutting her off her own hand wait
for what or cutting off her own hand she
must really love somebody
with a circular saw in order to cash
in a 1.2 million dollar insurance payout
oh
this is my soulmate oh so it's insurance
fraud
i was like wait are they is mutilation
illegal but now i get it it's because of
that
that's pretty hardcore though i don't
think i'd cut off my own hand for two
points i like how in joe's imagination
she's in the garage where all the tools
are at she's wearing
daisy dude shorts oh bikini top i was
going to see a white tank top
with see-through oh like that like
she's wearing a white shirt so it's all
like getting oh yeah leaky ac
yeah and then she cuts it off and she's
like well when it hits
when the saw hits the bone it's kind of
rough so it bounces a little bit
[ __ ] cities she's jiggling
jiggling
oh yeah
are we right are we right girlfriend
material i get it
wow we know that yeah good job team
thanks girls
but i don't like people that cut
themselves
but she didn't do it because she's sad
she's doing it because she's greedy
which i like she's an entrepreneur dude
that's different she has emotions no
she's a business
i think i don't like people that cut
themselves as a t-shirt yeah
[Laughter]
joe to sakawa t-shirt i don't like
people that cut themselves
because they're sad there you go
if they're greedy thumbs up
it's a good t-shirt only for an
insurance payout yeah
yeah and then it's like ooh i like you
you're driven this slovenian woman her
name is
jewel julia julia julie john
julian it's like julia but like yeah
yeah so it's like it spells like julia
but in between the i and the a there's a
j
what if they pronounce their j as like
like in uh
julia julia i don't know slovenian
accents or i don't know
isn't it millennial slovenian oh
millennial yeah
melania trump oh what they said
millennia yeah she was russian yeah
i don't know i think she's slovenian
yeah i think she's the pride and joy of
slovenia
okay yeah they produce very beautiful
women yeah trump
let's see she is slovenian okay good job
who did who guessed that
good guess i like eastern european women
okay
anyway back to julie jeff julia so
she's 22 years old currently this this
accidentally cutting her hand off
happened two years ago when she was 20.
and so she's saying that she
was she was trimming some branches or
sawing branches
at her home and that's when she like
severed her own hand off of her
like at the wrist wow and so her like
this
julia and her boyfriend went to the
hospital
leaving her hand behind at home what
went to the hospital but then the cops
were able to
go to her home retrieve the hand and
attach it back
but so it works i don't know exactly it
doesn't she's like no
no no it's not doing [ __ ] wow she just
has it like
but who's she going to stay this is what
she looks like so
um so she keeps her hand covered
so i don't know what it actually looks
like and then this is what she's
covering it on purpose
yeah and so are they walking damn we
weren't that off
here's what happened they oh so they
were trying to say like it was an
accident like oh [ __ ]
we left the house oh yay the cops got it
um
but yeah i'm so permanently damaged so
let me cash out the five insurance
policies that i got
which accumulate to 1.2 million cash out
i think you earned it
and also uh before that
so they were arrested they were they
were already investigating
her before giving her a payout all these
insurance companies
and so they found that the boyfriend had
previously searched
on google like how to live with a
prosthetic hand
see wow that's what was making me sad
because once i found out she had a
boyfriend in the mix i was like
he forced her to do this and also the
fact that they waited so they got these
insurance policies and then they had to
wait till like
they gave the first payment in order for
it to like be enacted or whatever
so the day after that their insurance
was
like good to go that's when the accident
happened oh come on
yeah so it's like come on okay that's
too obvious give it a week will ya
jesus coincidence is going on here
they're too greedy
like this is the hand cutting off policy
right listen good thing she got that
insurance because she was cut in
branches
and like and she doesn't look like she
does manual labor
she [ __ ] it all up true well she does
so her
like the defense they were trying to
bank on her looks and say
does this woman look like she would want
to [ __ ] herself on purpose
come on she's she's she's a 10. now
she's like a seven
yeah so she said it herself like why
would i do this to myself at the age of
20
i am now forever crippled who would do
this
not for end not for all the money in the
world i would never do this too much but
for five million she would
yeah she's trying to get 1.2 million 1.2
million yeah she had
five policies well out there at 1.2
million you could probably live forever
oh i mean like is this like vegas where
it's like unbelievable
it's probably cheaper than you got good
deals out there i think you could get
like a nice apartment for like
a couple hundred bucks a month what
would you guys be down to cut off
for like my ear what a whole lot that's
so hard
i
you have long hair you could cover it
wait your equilibrium is inside
like you're you're i thought you i
thought you needed the cones oh do you
isn't it the ticket this is just your
satellite dish
i'll just hold my hand look at that can
you hear me cup it see you hear me
better
it's like a tool but i heard that pigs
grow ears pretty good
like human ears and you could just get a
new one and people are growing ears and
body parts on their arms
like penises we talked about one they're
growing dicks on their arms now yes
a man a man had a dick i cut off like
this
part of my nose and this part of my nose
and this this part of my nose right here
you have plenty of those so much
it's all chiseled yeah like this just
this area right here that this is right
you'll cut like this if you want yeah
and like this yeah you don't want like
this we'll cut a little bit of that
in here too kind of maybe
and they give you a million dollars yeah
because i'm just saying why would i
disable my face like that i'd be like oh
no
not my precious stomach don't cut this
whatever you do don't just trim the
bottom fat no
yeah so she like i said previously she
got sentenced to two years in prison her
boyfriend
got a two-year prison sentence
as well oh no sorry three years she's
got [ __ ] up hand now
she doesn't get no insurance money
because the court was saying that the
boyfriend put her up to it and also the
boyfriend i don't like her no
[ __ ] the boyfriend is also being
tried as a suspected murderer
of his previous girlfriend who had died
they were together at the time of her
death back in 2015
he claims that her death was caused by a
shooting accident
oh no you know that we went to go shoot
box and then i
i killed her so he's like okay i tried
the shooting thing to get the insurance
that one doesn't work let's try a hand
instead for this girl
that's why when i heard that there was a
boyfriend in the mix i was like
she was forced to do this coerced she
was co-hers it wasn't her idea that's
why she got less of a
sentence than the boyfriend because
they're they have more proof
that the boyfriend was planning it was
premeditated at least from the
boyfriend's side
because girls do anything for that dick
i know right
sometimes sometimes if it's a good dick
you know but cutting
your hand off she had a bit this guy's
like a master manipulator i bet yeah
yeah
yeah oh this is what he looks like by
the way yes he's sexy
okay see it oh wait yeah it's a sexy man
aren't you all right this guy sorry that
guy's sexier than the other guy
he's the jailer this guy that guy he's
wearing a uniform he can't see his eyes
his dreamy eyes
yeah they're probably like ocean blue or
like ice blue got strong hairline though
i'll say that
that's like that's a good good ass
that's a widow's peak if i've ever seen
one
what is that a drag account dracula
hairline
or a steep green
when he just suddenly realizes his world
is collapsing around him this is my
resting face damn that's crazy
and also the woman's father got a
one-year suspended sentence
as well as like the father's woman okay
they're all trash
cause like yeah because he knew about it
he was involved somehow
this good idea you have two hands why
you know one is fine you get hooked
very useful it also seemed obvious to me
that it was
done on purpose too because it's like
it's her left hand like why would she's
right-handed
and then also just like cleanly at the
wrist like come on who did it
oh my god i can't do it myself
if i'm gonna he probably did it i would
have someone else do it
i wouldn't i wouldn't do it myself i
don't know i would pass the [ __ ] out i
have to do it myself really
i have to do it myself i need to do what
they do in the movies where they find
like a stick and you gotta
fight this and you get a swig of whiskey
no
i would hate you forever if i did it
yeah i would hate the person that did it
to me i don't know because i'm just
gonna get what if it was your scam yeah
what if it's your idea not just that but
think about this
what if you're you think you're numb
because you're probably going to want to
numb yourself right you think that
you're numb and then you're doing it
yourself you're like oh [ __ ] i don't
feel anything from the skin cool
you get closer and closer to the center
and i think i would go that slow and
it's not well no because
i'm saying like what if what if you're
trying but then like you hit a nerve and
you [ __ ] it up and you just have half of
a hand like
[ __ ] falling i think it's [ __ ]
having someone else do it because they
can't feel the nerves
they can't feel the pain yeah it's
harder to do this
than someone else come and just do this
i'd rather
i'd rather do an axe too just yeah it's
done
cha-cha saw two it's like it's moving
some more [ __ ] you imagine all her flesh
just [ __ ] flying out but then the
saw on the bonus would get to these oh
[ __ ] those teens are [ __ ] really
moving now
you know what i should do i should
create uh a hand guillotine
for those who want a clean cut for their
insurance
oh i'm done with that then the shirts
will be like did you use the hand
guillotine
no no no no no no no we found this box
in your garbage it's the hangulatine box
oh [ __ ]
it's a product anyone can buy it's like
all packaged i'll have an infomercial
you guys want insurance money check this
out baby
on the box it says guaranteed insurance
money
hello
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you